PROFESSOR: How can I recommend
you to world class faculty
members here at MIT
if you're sloppy?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL: One of the students
doesn't want to confess to
spilling half a bottle of
hazardous chemical on the
laboratory floor.
I mean, that's a major
safety hazard.
IKE: Did you guys
know who did it?
PHIL: No.
IKE: Yeah, I can't tell you.
I'm a brother.
I'm a homey.
PHIL: This is when
we have a witch
trial like in The Crucible.
And if nobody confesses, we
send everybody home, and
everyone gets an
F for the day.
IKE: [BLEEP]
was the one who spilled
the urea.
Don't tell [INAUDIBLE].
Don't tell.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL: Pretty angry.
I would say it was urea, but
we can't know for sure.
So.
IKE: But he knows himself.
He knows himself.
[LAUGHS]
It's a secret.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL: Recently across the
country and, of course,
throughout time, there's been
waves of serious injuries and
deaths as a result of not
following best safety
practices in the laboratory.
PROFESSOR: The labs have
not been cleaned.
Chemicals, basically, have been
spilled on the scales and
on the floor.
PHIL: If somebody steps in
that, they track it home.
It's on your shoes.
It gets on your rug.
PROFESSOR: You come in, and
you spill the chemicals.
And then, you just disappear.
And that is just not right.
PHIL: Next thing you know,
you're doing Pilates in a
puddle of urea.
HANSOL: He's basically
yelled at us.
That's as far as he's going
to get in terms
of yelling at students.
PROFESSOR: I forgot
you're freshmen.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to give you a fresh
start today.
You're going to clean
up your act.
Today's your new start.